so for today's classic interview we're
gonna revisit the concept of morality
without religion and this is a topic
we've discussed on the program many
times before and I think it's
particularly relevant right now because
we recently did the story we're in a
debate with Matt Dillahunty Jordan
Peterson argued that you can't really
say whether you can have morality
without religion because deep down even
atheists who appear to be moral and
claim not to believe in God actually do
so we can't really say whether you can
have morality without religion that's
the sort of overarching context in which
we'll revisit my interview from January
of 2016 with AC grayling about morality
without religion I'm joined today by
Professor AC grayling professor of
philosophy and master of new college of
the humanities in London it's so great
to have you on so many people have
recommended that we speak to you and I
think a good sort of general place to
start would be you've talked about
ethics and morality and religion and
humanism question one for those who may
be uninitiated in the topic our humanism
and atheism connected are they
overlapping are they different but
similar in some way let's start there
for our our audience Steve I mean it is
important to in fact to distinguish not
merely atheism and humanism but also
secularism because these these the three
of other different things
atheism is a debate between people who
have a religious conviction of some kind
the theists and those who don't the
atheists and that's ultimately a
metaphysical debate about what there is
in the universe what exists or doesn't
exist in particular whether there are
any transcendent agencies or some kind
sitters debate of course is about the
case of the religious voice in the
public square and how much influence it
has on public policy matters and in that
respect a religious person could very
well be a secularist because religious
person could think that church and state
matters ought to be kept apart a
humanism is an ethical outlook
it is very naturally the ethical Apple
but a non-religious person might hold
because of course if you have a
religious commitment to some kind it's
quite likely that you think that your
moral outlook your behavior your
relationships with others should be
governed by what and arg says or desires
requires of you whereas the humanist
having no religious outlook will say
it's our responsibility to think very
seriously and carefully about how would
you live our lives what kind of people
where should be that's the big Socratic
challenge and also how very important to
you where to relate to others so there
is a natural connection between atheism
and humanism but it is possible for non
a theist s' let us say agnostics perhaps
or even people who have a very liberal
view of religion perhaps characteristic
residual religion to think that the
ethical infections will be Prevost on
concerns about what it is to be human
I'd love to get a little bit into the
discussion around ethics and what is
ethical and in many of my conversations
with those who say they are devoutly
religious one of their main sort of when
you ask them why is religion needed in
their mind they say well religion gives
us a moral and ethical code and without
a moral and ethical code presented by
religion any analysis that we make about
what actions are or are not ethical
would be sort of arbitrary in a sense
now for example sam harris in his book
the moral landscape he says no actually
science can tell us what is good or bad
we can make objective determinations
about increasing well-being versus
decreasing it and we can get a sort of
ethical code as to what is good or bad
from science I'd be curious where you
fit into this debate but let me say
first that it's very important to
distinguish ethics and morality when
people who use the conjunction ethics
and morality think that they're speaking
about the same thing but actually
they're wise of them they know the idea
of ethics
from an ancient Greek concept concept
authority means character and so when we
have thoughts about ethical lives we're
thinking about that question I mentioned
earlier what sort of people should we be
how should we live what values should
shape and color our attitude towards
life morality is a much narrower thing
it concerns the question of our
responsibilities towards one another and
moral outlooks change over time rather
like a pendulum swinging backwards and
forwards you get more and less liberal
attitudes more or less puritanical
attitudes but ethical reflection can
very often often does modify and enrich
our moral understanding so for example
the position of gay people in society as
once regarded with a great deal of
horror and outrage and opposition but
ethical reflection on that moral view
change that value and now we have a much
more humane and sensible and accepting
attitude which is a good thing and that
is the result of course of ethical views
I think and some sin hearses view Mike
and one might express it perhaps better
this way which is to say that reason the
application of reason and the knowledge
that we've accumulated about human
nature in the human condition about
human desires and interests and needs
through the great conversation of
humankind that is embodied in the future
in history and in philosophical
reflection that is what provides us with
a very deep and substantial resource for
thinking about ethics and it is that
reflection it is that conversation that
we have with ourselves and with one
another about the right and the good
about the best kind of society and about
what really matters in individual human
lives that helps us to developing an
ethics of generosity and sympathy and of
kindness towards one another which is
based purely on this power that we have
the power of reason and the power of
imagination which enables us to
understand how things are for somebody
else whose lives we don't share
necessarily now for the religious
individual who might hear you and say
well it sounds
me sort of like a semantic argument
which is that while we can objectively
determine what is ethical based on our
ability to reason couldn't our ability
to reason or the way in which we reason
also sort of evolve or change and then
does it not become just as subjective as
saying oh religion a says X Y & Z about
what is ethical in other words isn't
there the same amount of subjectivity in
our ability to reason I don't think so I
think there is a great deal of
intersubjectivity that's to say we learn
from one another we confront one another
we challenge one another we debate these
matches and we find that there is a
great deal the factor of agreement in
sympathy within groups about how we
should comport ourselves and then
sometimes we major differences between
groups of course that's perfectly true
but this is something which the the long
unfolding story of history teaches us a
valuable lesson about which is that this
time goes by so I think our societies
and our individual moralities do
incrementally inch by inch sometimes
with a step or two backless very couple
steps forward does seem to make progress
for example I'm very very impressed
indeed by Steven Pinker's book the
better angels of our nature which you
may remember yes and shows us that in
fact societies do seem so lean over time
but should be growing and really rather
much better in these respects and I
would certainly mark this progress by
saying the following and very very
occasionally people say would you like
to live in some other part of history
and I say well yeah you know if I could
take my dentist with me certainly I'd
like to it'd be very interesting the
times in the past there should be an
observer of but I wouldn't like to live
anywhere other than the modern West and
today if I were a woman so I think that
is a a marker of just how much progress
there has been over history and this is
ethical progress I would be interested
to hear you talk a little bit about the
influence that you believe organized
religion has had on society and you've
talked about factors in your writing
which I've read
factors and influences that historically
have divided and United human beings and
before we sort of dig in to a more
specific discussion of this when you
think back over human history and this
is I think a good segue given your
discussion about living in the modern
West as sort of the the preferred choice
for you currently what factors have been
the biggest dividing factors for humans
during the observable history and what
factors have been uniting for human
beings well and that there is a kind of
watershed in human affairs in at least
the history of the West which is that
prior to the late fourth century of the
Common Era and and in fact one could
even attach a day trip which is the 380
of the Common Era which is when the
Edict of Thessalonica was issued and
making the Christian religion the only
permissible religion in the Roman Empire
that prior to that time that the Roman
about was very syncretism and that
allowed many many different religions to
flourish there were many different
ethnicities languages and traditions
within the Roman Empire which for its
time was was vast and so religious
practice there was a rather different
thing from what we think of it now for
example the word itself religio religion
and Latin means to bind or to bring
together and so the idea was that in the
public festivals of worship of the
Emperor's it might be or the Imperial
and pantheon the society was being
brought together as a single cohesive
whole
but what Christianity borrowed from the
mystery would its answer to very much a
kind of minority comes beforehand was
this idea of a much more personal
relationship a much more powerful and
Imperial energy requiring something of
the individual and so the idea of
religion and religious practice very
much changed and with that change came
not the binding together and bringing it
together over of an empire but divisions
the first divisions of course within
Christianity itself regarding
heretics and a difference in sometimes
but powerfully different movements
within Christianity and to learn
orthodoxy was arrived at briefly for a
couple of centuries that appositives
degree schism between Rome and the
Orthodox communions then there was the
Reformation and so on and unfortunately
and with also the outbreak of Islam the
tensions between the different groups
within Christianity and between
Christians in Islam has resulted in a
very very long period indeed of
confrontation religious wars
persecutions because the differences of
opinion and the like and that I'm afraid
has been continuing running saw a cancer
if you like on history ever since the
late 4th century I don't want for for a
moment to deny that there have been
plenty of good things that have come out
of religion accidentally and directly
accidentally I think greater
architecture and not a fool Archer said
to live in the church hang on
commissioning power so as a result we
have some wonderful works of art
paintings music and the like great
architecture but um I think on balance
and by a considerable margin the results
of this change in the nature of religion
in about the fourth century has been a
divisive in a destructive way now if you
were to speak to the adherents either of
Islam or or any particular Christian
sect some of them as they have told me
would likely tell you well it might
appear as though our religion or our
sect within our religion has been
divisive in terms of its influence but
if only everyone just followed our
version of our religion all of that
divisive 'no swiff goat would go away
what's the best retort to that is it the
pragmatic retort that that's just never
going to happen so we shouldn't even
think of it it's just a utopian fantasy
or is there a different way we can
respond to that but hey the divisive 'no
scums from all of the other sects not
from ours well of course there's happy
situations where both sides of that
conversation just reported all right i
mean if everybody agreed with that
particular sect then indeed there would
be no there will be no conflict
well they're human nature being what it
is I'm pretty sure some calls of
dissension or disagreement might ledger
and rise because we are after all a
disputatious species but you also are
right I mean that the fact is that it's
extremely unlikely that the different
sects will ever agree I mean if you look
at the history and we have a rather
amusing example here in our own Islands
in Britain of the the Scottish Church
which is split and split again split
again into ever smaller fragments and
breakaway groups so we have the the Free
Church and then we have what are known
as the we freeze we being a Scottish
word for small and then then we we
freeze the small small please would
broke away from small reasons right and
so on so I mean I do think that the
wonderful logic - film The Life of Brian
really does some time we've been
speaking with Professor AC grayling
professor of philosophy and master of
New College of the humanities in London
it's really so great to speak to you and
I'd love to have you back absolutely any
time great pleasure to be on your show